[inaudible],
you know,
since we're here at Google and we know that we love numbers,
I thought I'd start this introduction with some numbers.
A one in five women in America have been to a planned parenthood last year.
Planned parenthood provides 10.6 million services,
uh,
over 270,000 pap smears,
360,000 breast exams,
4.2 million tests and treatments for sexual transmitted diseases including a
650,000 HIV test.
A 97% of what they do is not about abortion.
And I think we always have to remind ourselves of that only 3% is.
And what I think is so amazing is that planned parenthood has been around for a
hundred years is our a hundredth anniversary this year.
Yeah.
Wow.
I know.
Feel has led this organization for the last 10.
Uh,
and I think first why don't we start out with,
um,
there's a lot of misconceptions about what planned parenthood is,
what it does.
Can you kind of clear that up and tell us what we all do?
Well,
you did a great job.
I think.
Just interject and in the introduction,
and let me just say thank you also for having me here at Google.
We love Google is the way probably most of the people find us now and which is,
has just been amazing to see the last 10 years of transformation,
that access on the web and on mobile phones has made.
So yeah,
for,
as you said it,
and we see about two and half million patients a year.
We were in every single state,
red and blue and purple.
It doesn't matter.
And the patients who come to us,
it's always say they're not coming to make a political statement.
They were coming because they need access to high quality and affordable
healthcare.
And in a lot of parts of the country,
we are the only doctor that women will see it.
Maybe they're only medical visit.
And that's an incredibly important part of what we're talking about now because
I think there's so much at risk for women's health and for basic basic access to
healthcare,
uh,
not only here in California,
but particularly in some of the Midwestern states and southern states where
there just aren't,
um,
health centers on every corner for,
for everybody who needs them.
And the only thing I'd say that's important is half of our health centers are
located in medically underserved communities.
So we were proud to be there for folks who again,
may not have a lot of other options.
That's great.
So just,
I can't even believe it was month ago,
uh,
was the,
women's march and you were a key participants in that.
Can you talk to us about how that began and how it all
ruin what you thought of that?
Well,
the amazing thing about the march,
and it wasn't even a march,
it was marches,
right?
That was what it was,
I think so stunning is that I,
and I was in Washington DC,
which was,
the march was so enormous and so many more showed up that there was no marching.
I mean,
they were just sort of standing in place.
I'm moving back and forth.
Uh,
but it,
and it was extraordinary.
It was really a civilian led march,
if you will.
And was started by some women who just felt that they wanted to organize
something.
And then what we saw is it just grew around the country.
And to me,
the thing that was amazing,
and I know here in California,
folks marched in San Francisco in the rain,
and I think Los Angeles had just record crowds,
but also,
uh,
places like El Centro.
And,
you know,
every town,
we had 10,000 people in Salt Lake City,
Utah.
And then there's a great photograph of folks in Fairbanks,
Alaska,
in the snow,
in a blizzard,
like with their signs.
Uh,
uh,
so to me that was,
that was the extraordinary thing is it wasn't,
uh,
March,
about the coasts.
It was a march of more than 4 million people in this country saying,
we believe in women's rights and women's equality.
And I think the other part of that was so stunning and you just couldn't help.
But,
uh,
well I guess two things.
One is there were women of sort of my mother's generation that were marching
with signs saying things like,
I can't believe I still have to protest this,
fill in the blank.
Um,
and,
and then people who had never marched to their lives,
you know,
young people for whom this was just a completely transformative experience.
And then you couldn't help but be blown away by the number of men who are
marching.
And maybe some of you in this room,
I don't know.
But,
uh,
um,
it was,
there were fathers marching with their granddaughters and there were,
um,
brothers marching with,
and four,
there were sisters.
And to me that was the big theme,
which is I just think that,
um,
no one wants to see their daughters have fewer rights than they did.
And,
and I think there's a generational shift happening in real tipping point here
that men want their daughters to have every opportunity that there,
that their sons have.
And that means being able to finish school,
that means being able to get a career,
maybe work for Google,
maybe do whatever they want to do.
And part of that means being in control of your reproductive health.
Right.
When I was talking to a lot of people and asking me what I should ask you,
um,
and knowing we're problem solvers here,
uh,
it was interesting to hear people say the largest share of what you do isn't
about abortion,
but you're so pinned as abortion.
Do you ever find that if we,
if you marketed yourself as differently,
if you didn't speak out so much about that it's still did them,
but you might have more success.
Have you ever thought about that?
Well,
actually I think that people that are obsessed with abortion are the people who
are against it.
And,
um,
so I,
I would say that we are,
we are very proud to provide all reproductive healthcare access and that
includes safe and legal abortion.
It is still a legal right in this country and
mmm,
I do.
I think it's important that we don't do anything more to stigmatize or shame
people who have made that decision.
And I think it's,
it's just an important part of women's health care access.
The,
the interesting thing is I do think there was some times,
uh,
there was sort of folks who consume a lot of news and think that this is all the
conversation and this is what everybody is thinking about when,
of course the vast majority of our patients come to us for basic preventive
care.
Yeah.
Um,
our support is at record numbers.
We're at 70% of people in this country actually not only support planned
parenthood,
but think we should be funded and actually support for Roe versus Wade is at the
highest point it ever has been 70% of the country.
Again.
So I think we,
we make a mistake sometimes when we don't lean into,
um,
to quote a friend of mine,
uh,
lean into the fact that this is a,
this is a right,
that's been established for many,
many years.
It's access that people need.
And quite frankly,
if we could quit obsessing over this and actually talk about the fact that,
I mean maybe something you want to talk about.
We were making historic gains and reducing unintended pregnancy,
uh,
teenage pregnancy.
I can give you the numbers.
It's amazing.
And that's the bulk of what we do is help people prevent an unintended pregnancy
and stay healthy and safe.
But we have to spend too much of our time fighting with politicians who want to
end women's rights and women's access to care.
Yeah.
Prompts to issues.
Uh,
one which you alluded to,
uh,
for those of you don't realize we were at a 30 year low for unwanted pregnancies
and at record lows for teenage pregnancies.
Yep.
Uh,
do you take responsibility for that?
Well,
not personally.
I've talked to a ton of people,
but I don't know that it's made that big an impact.
But I will say this is where,
again,
I think it's important to link,
like why things change in government has the biggest influence on people's lives
at any other institution.
And that's just the truth.
So if you don't vote,
you get the government that,
um,
you know,
sort of someone else's notes for.
I had the real honor,
uh,
during President Obama's presidency to work very hard sometimes with the
administration,
sometimes fighting the administration to expand access to healthcare.
And one of the things that planned parenthood really lead on was the birth
control benefit.
Now,
55 million women in this country have access to no cost,
birth control and their insurance plans.
Yeah.
This is revolutionary.
And
yeah,
it really is.
Um,
and we were talking,
I was telling you a story.
Uh,
my sister's an ob and one day she had come home,
this was several years ago and said,
uh,
this woman was pregnant and you know,
distraught about it.
And what made it so bad was she was a poor woman,
uh,
working for,
and she had to choose between paying her electric bill and taking birth control.
That's right.
And,
uh,
so she was taking pills every other day trying to stretch them,
you know,
and it didn't work.
And I think sometimes,
and if you could talk to this,
we forget that it's a struggle.
If you can't afford birth,
you're absolutely right.
And I could recount story after story of folks who have come to planned
parenthood.
Uh,
a couple of things that are important for those of you are interested in the
health care side.
One of the problems with birth control has been that women would just choose the
cheapest kind,
whatever they can that's usually meant birth control pills and which are not the
most reliable for the one.
One of the reasons is what you mentioned.
So the exciting thing to us as women have been able to now choose a birth
control that works best for them.
And that includes many times long acting methods like an Iud.
And in fact,
one of the craziest things was within the two days after the election,
we had a 900% increase in women trying to get an Iud at planned parenthood that
would last for years.
Um,
and uh,
so,
uh,
that is so that'll just show you that women are very aware of what they need and
how expensive it can be.
Here's a,
here's an interesting economic fact.
After the birth control benefit went into,
went into effect before it was even in effect for everyone.
Women saved one point $4 billion on just birth control pills in the first year
alone.
Now for anyone who thinks that that doesn't make a difference in the lives of
women who are struggling to pay rent,
young women who are in college and have to choose sometimes between groceries
and birth control,
that is just not a choice any woman should ever have to make.
And you know,
we may talk about the threats that Speaker Ryan has made to defund planned
parenthood.
Ironically,
we're the largest provider of women's reproductive health care in the country.
This is what we've been doing for a hundred years.
I feel like we keep getting better at it and,
and anything now we should double down on these kinds of services because
they're working for women and working for families.
Talk,
I think a little bit about some of the,
we'll call them case studies of what happens when those rights who are rooted in
what you've seen in some of the areas where uh,
people don't have access to.
Sure.
I know cause we discussed a little bit that we live in a pretty wonderful place
here.
If those of you are from the bay area or California and it's great to have
states like California,
I don't know my colleague from more Monte may be here,
but constantly just pushing the envelope,
you know,
really expanding access.
Well,
I happened to come from Texas and I know that one of my colleagues,
one of my friends is here from Houston,
who knows what it's like down there.
It is not the same.
Uh,
we,
we had a state legislature there that declared war on women's health.
They basically ended the women's healthcare program that had been operating for
many,
many years.
Dozens of women's health centers,
not just planned parenthood,
but others were shutdown.
So places that women had gotten birth control or gotten their cancer screenings
and uh,
it has absolutely impacted women's health.
We've seen a doubling of the maternal mortality rate in the state of Texas.
And the thing to me,
and it's something that I think we should also think about in terms of the
impact of these policies,
the folks that get hurt are the women who have the least access to care.
You know,
there are other women who they lose their benefits,
they're going to figure something out.
But if you look at low income women of color in,
they're the ones who have really been hurt,
uh,
and hit the hardest.
And that's to me that what's so discouraging about some of the proposals and the
actions of the legislature,
they are,
but now our federal government is that it's going to hurt women who have,
are finally beginning to make some progress here.
And I think they were talking about just turning it all back.
Yeah.
Can you,
uh,
I think,
the Washington term of defunding planned parenthood is a bit,
a little bit of,
uh,
not the correct term.
It's right.
It's not.
Yeah.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Sure.
No,
I appreciate it.
So that's what is what Paul Ryan said,
the second day of Congress that he was going to,
when they're going to repeal the affordable care act,
there are also going to defund planned parenthood.
Um,
and by the way,
within two hours,
you couldn't get a phone call into Paul Ryan's office.
I mean,
it was just an explosion.
And even in the last few weeks,
I mean,
it has been record numbers of calls to Congress.
They have literally shut down the congressional switchboard.
So all of you are calling members of Congress,
keep doing it.
It's working and it's,
it's incredibly important.
So
yeah,
to do that,
what it would mean,
and this is really important.
So thanks for giving me like a little bit of a chance to explain.
Uh,
we see,
uh,
about half the patients we see are on public assistance of some sort,
primarily Medicaid and title 10,
which is the national family planning program.
So,
uh,
and federal funds do not pay for abortion.
They have not for decades.
Now.
We think that's wrong and we believe it is hurt.
Low income women.
Uh,
I'm fairly for many,
many,
many years,
but that is the law of the land.
And planned parenthood obeys the law to the letter.
So what they're talking about doing is saying women and young people are men who
come to us for cancer screenings,
birth control,
STI testing and treatment.
Well,
woman visits,
they can't come to us anymore for those basic preventive care.
And that we believe is illegal and we will fight them in court.
But first we want to beat it in Congress if we can because we don't think it's
right.
We just believe that if a member of Congress can choose where they want to go to
for healthcare than women in America should have the same.
Right.
[inaudible]
if I can't,
I'll,
I'll just mention one other things I suppose.
Right.
Interesting.
I'm actually,
I'll be going tomorrow to Wisconsin and that's the state where we are major
family planning provider,
especially in rural,
small town Wisconsin and in,
in Speaker Ryan's own district,
we have three planned parenthood health centers.
We don't provide abortion services and those centers we provide preventive
healthcare,
family planning and so on.
And in one of those towns racing,
seeing we are the only safety net provider in racing Wisconsin.
And so essentially what Paul Ryan is saying and politicians who agree with him
is that those folks are going to be left out of the healthcare system.
Um,
and again,
so at the same time they were both wanting to repeal the affordable care act,
take away their health insurance and then take away the only healthcare provider
that they have.
Uh,
that's why I think you're seeing thousands of people actually rise up and speak
out.
And that's what we'll be doing in Wisconsin this weekend.
Oh,
good.
Yeah,
that'll be fun.
MMM.
Talk a little bit about,
um,
your newest constituent or I guess you say you're growing constituent of the
trans community and treating them shortly with,
you know,
what's the latest thing is,
no,
exactly.
And we were talking about this a lot last night and I was in San Francisco.
I mean,
we are proud our,
our motto at Planned Parenthood is Karen,
no matter what.
And that means no matter where your income,
your,
um,
your background,
uh,
where you live,
no matter you know,
who you love,
how you love.
And we've been proud to serve the transgender community here in the bay area.
I know we provide services we do in 16 states around the country and it's
continuing to grow.
Uh,
and that only not only a means providing specific services like hormone
replacement therapy,
but also plate.
I hope being a place where the trans community can come to for basic healthcare
and feel welcomed and not shamed and not stigmatized in any way.
It has been heartbreaking to hear the stories of what the Trans Community faces
just to get basic access to healthcare in America.
And this decision by the administration to repeal the just some basic rights for
young people in this country is heartbreaking and it's wrong.
And we have to fight back at every single opportunity.
It's just
so,
and I,
and I will add,
we are very proud and always have served anyone regardless of their immigration
status or the refugee status.
And we always will because healthcare should be a human right.
It shouldn't be a privilege and an honor.
No,
you have this,
um,
amazing or around you and you're at this fighter.
Um,
but you don't,
you I should say you come by it honestly.
And we would talk a little bit about,
uh,
your mom who I'm a huge fan of a hope for those who don't know her mother.
Is Ann Richards or was Ann Richardson who is the governor of Texas,
went from school teacher to governor.
It was rice and her father was a,
is a major civil rights lawyer.
Argued in front of the Supreme Court.
Yeah.
Dad is going to be so thrilled when he got,
he made Google,
well,
I have to tell him,
I mean it,
but what is it like to grow up in that family be expected to be out there?
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I,
so I grew up in Texas and my parents were kind of,
um,
they were fighting everything in Texas and so,
but it was a,
it was a very privileged childhood.
I will say when everything that came through town,
my folks were into the civil rights movement and the women's movement and the
farm workers movement.
And my dad was defending conscientious objectors to the Vietnam war.
And so it was a place where they really taught us that you could make a
difference in this world.
And um,
and so from a very early age,
we had that opportunity.
Um,
and one thing we were talking about earlier,
which is kind of funny,
my,
my folks,
uh,
eventually they moved to Austin,
which was just frankly a more hospitable climate for their progressive.
Uh,
and there was a young woman who wanted to run for the state legislature.
And it's funny cause she wanted to run for the state legislature because she
couldn't get credit in her own name,
even though she was an attorney,
even though she had argued before the supreme court,
but she had to have her husband cosign.
I'm telling you guys,
this is like,
we're not that far away from this.
And so she wanted to run for the state legislature to change this and she
couldn't find a man to run a race.
And so my mother said,
well,
I'll do it.
And her name is Sarah Weddington.
And uh,
she was Sarah for those who don't know,
argued the Roe vs Wade case at the age of 26 years old.
So get busy like whatever you're doing now.
Um,
and uh,
anyway,
it was really interesting.
So mom,
you know,
as kids we got to,
do the kinds of things you do as kids on campaigns and learn those skills.
And Sarah one and then of course mom got the bug and decided if she can do it,
why don't I run?
And eventually was elected the first a pro choice woman governor of the state of
Texas.
Yeah.
So it was pretty,
it was exciting time.
Yeah.
And do you think that,
uh,
I mean that has to be a little weird.
I mean to Sarah here and then planned parenthood.
Have you ever kind of thought about that?
Well,
it's just funny.
I was in Houston last weekend.
They actually had the biggest planned parenthood luncheon in the history of the
organization.
And I mean,
that's what we're seeing around the country is folks just coming out in such big
ways.
And it was wonderful because Sarah was there and another good friend of mine,
Wendy Davis,
who of course led the historic filibuster in the state capitol in Texas.
So it was pretty,
it was pretty awesome.
Yeah.
So I think there's also a misconception that if the government wouldn't pay you
back for the services that maybe all this money and goodwill and all this stuff
that's coming in would be able to keep you all flipped.
Is that,
that's a great,
that's a great question.
Yeah.
And I should've probably finished on the whole defunding question.
We,
we operate just like hospitals and all of their healthcare providers and we just
get reimbursed for services.
And so really the defunding is,
we're not in the federal budget.
We just,
they're just saying,
you could no longer actually provide that care to folks.
There's no way you could make up for all the public services that we provide
through private donations.
Even though we're incredibly grateful for the outpouring of support and,
and in addition,
I just think it's so important this country that we,
that we hold up and hold onto public health care as a,
as an important value.
We can't prioritize healthcare in this country because when we do folks who,
who miss out or the folks who have the most,
most need,
uh,
to get healthcare.
And so I just think this is going to be a big,
a big fight here,
um,
about the belief in the public healthcare system that it's a value not only for
individuals but for our communities and for our economy.
Yeah.
Do you think,
uh,
back to abortion for just one sec,
if just for something would happen and you wouldn't be able to provide abortion,
there's this concern,
this idea that then it would be over that abortion would not happen.
Can you kind of,
they would just,
yeah.
I think that having a place that provides a safe place to have an abortion,
it's important.
Right,
right.
I mean,
abortion existed before Roe versus Wade.
It was just illegal and it was unsafe and young,
healthy women died routinely and emergency rooms across this country.
Yeah.
In fact,
I was in San Francisco last night and there was a doctor there who wrote,
who was telling me he remembers in his residency seeing women with septic
abortions,
uh,
coming into the hospitals.
So it's not that abortion won't exist,
it's that it will be unsafe.
Uh,
and you know,
it's,
it's already in many areas of the country.
87% of the counties in this country don't have any abortion providers.
So women already face enormous obstacles,
particularly if they're low income or if they live in a state where there,
um,
where the politics make it very difficult.
To me,
the most important thing is that we make sure that it's safe and available for
people,
that it's legal,
uh,
and that we do everything we can to make sure that folks have access to
preventive care that helps prevent unintended pregnancy in the first place.
And,
and frankly,
that's something that the vast majority of Americans agree on.
And I'll just put it in this one.
Political plug is if more members of Congress could get pregnant,
we look at fighting about a lot of these issues.
[inaudible]
take questions in just a second.
But,
um,
I wanted to ask,
you know,
once again,
we live in California
and we can,
you know,
call our congressman,
call everyone,
but we are preaching to the choir a bit.
What can we else can we do to help you?
Well,
why it still is important to call your members of Congress because I was
actually just in,
in Washington and speaking through to a number of the senators and it makes a
difference when they hear from you.
And uh,
can I just say thanks for sending Camilla Harris to the United States
part of that.
She's,
she's,
uh,
she's already making a huge difference.
So it does matter actually,
uh,
that,
that you get involved.
The other thing you can do is be a defender and sign up with planned
parenthood.org and sign up to be a volunteer because there were actions that
we're asking people to take every single week.
And you can do that no matter where you live.
And if you're in virtual,
uh,
if you're a Google or out there in the world,
um,
we would love to have that.
And then the third thing is something that is just critically important.
That is the work you took.
Google.
I mean,
I can't overstate,
I,
you know,
back in the olden days when I started playing parents,
I was like,
oh my God,
the Internet and,
and planned parenthood where like a match made in heaven.
Because if the idea of planned period has always been to reduce access at me,
reduced barriers to care,
uh,
and barriers to lifesaving information,
we now see more people,
um,
through Google every month than we do,
you know,
in an entire year.
I mean,
literally,
I think in,
in January,
almost 10 million people came to us online.
And it's everything from being able to find a health center to getting
information about something you don't know about,
uh,
to,
um,
uh,
texting with us if you want to talk to someone in that way.
And so thank you for always thinking about creative ways that we can take away
the,
not only the cultural barriers but the literal barriers that folks have,
um,
have in getting care.
Because you mentioned being in San Francisco here,
it is a good supportive community,
although I don't want to overstate that.
Still people struggle.
It's not that there's no place that's easy for everyone,
but the work that we're doing in California,
uh,
in terms of now being able to give access to birth control online and even do
STI testing and treatment,
um,
virtually so that we can send,
send 'em both pharmaceuticals and testing kits has really made a difference.
And we just dropped,
shipped us a birth control to women who want to Arctic glacier literally had,
um,
uh,
through a video chat had,
had gotten a birth control appointment.
So I just think the opportunities we have to apply technology to the issues that
we work on is limitless.
And thanks,
thanks to Google for being such a great partner over us.
Appreciate it.
You're welcome.
So
I want to make sure that I don't just talk.
So clip,
I think it could ask some of the dory
low on the topic of transgender,
Karen that you mentioned before.
I have two related questions.
First of all,
you said only in 19 states,
what is preventing you from expanding this to all 50 states?
And secondly,
uh,
I noticed that you still use women centric language,
talking about dealing with Eh,
giving women access to abortion and birth control.
Obviously transgender men also need those same services.
Are you planning on using more inclusive language in that?
Yup.
Thank you.
Quite well taken.
Thank you very much for that.
Um,
and you're exactly,
you're exactly right.
And in terms of,
in terms of transgender care,
it's being just expanded state by state,
by state,
and it's ugly.
I think it's only a matter of time and I think that the uptake has been very,
very fast and we're proud to do that and we got to,
we're going to fight to stay open so that we can continue to expand access to
care because both of these things kind of go hand in hand.
Uh,
but thank you for your advocacy.
Thank you for your question.
Uh,
and we always tried to do,
do better in making sure that everyone can come to us for care regardless of
what they need.
Can you think for one second men coming to planned parenthood,
what percentage of your clients are men?
Um,
about 10%.
And it's,
um,
it's growing particularly because a lot of folks come to us for STI testing and
treatment,
which is a matter not only have I think convenience,
but I hope also of being a welcoming place.
And I mean,
I think of like I grew up in Texas where you didn't always want to just go to
your family doctor or sexual reproductive health care issues.
And so I think it's so important that we provide a place that,
um,
uh,
that people feel welcome and that's includes,
um,
for testing.
I know.
I was in San Diego the other day,
uh,
at one of the health centers and I looked into the waiting room and um,
usually it's the soaps on or something on the TV,
but it was ESPN and it was full of,
you know,
it was all guys,
it looked like in the waiting room and it turned out it was a vasectomy day at
planned parenthood,
which is cool.
Um,
so anyway,
yeah.
Thank you for coming today.
I wanted to ask a question based on your,
I would check your sources.
Uh,
wonderful and legendary moment.
Right now.
We know the facts,
we know the numbers,
but in the administration they are blatantly making that an issue.
They are promoting alternative facts and the true in Congress as well.
And so many people are believing that around the country.
How do we constructively engage those people,
both the leadership and of course the average person on the street who believes
this stuff,
to help them really understand what the true issues are.
The true numbers behind planned parenthood and other similar organizations.
Look,
if I could figure out a way to,
uh,
solve the fake news problem,
I'd probably be at another line of work.
And I had I,
and I think it's,
but it is incredibly disturbing.
And when you have folks in elective office who are willing to misstate the truth
over and over again,
and that's why frankly,
everyone here is important.
People lifting up,
um,
real information and it,
but it is very difficult because I see members of Congress say things that are
absolutely untrue.
Some of them I don't even know that they know,
uh,
or I don't know if it's they don't know or they don't care to find out the
truth.
I will say I have been just so encouraged and excited to see hundreds of
thousands of people showing up at town hall meetings now with members of
Congress.
That's the only way I know to really get truth out there.
And people telling their own personal stories and experiences with planned
parenthood.
Those are things that are irrefutable and I get,
I think sometimes we get caught up too much in numbers and we really have to
lift up the,
the lived experiences that people have in this country trying to access
reproductive health care,
accessing planned parenthood,
accessing other,
um,
other healthcare access.
It is at risk.
And I look,
I don't know that we're going to turn things around overnight,
but support in this country not only for planned parenthood but for,
for reproductive rights and reproductive access is growing.
And that's because of people speaking up and speaking out.
I think the only thing I would ask folks of if I feel like we're all going to
have to do things that are tougher than anything we've ever done because we're
living at a time that is really has been not like anything we've ever
experienced.
And so if you have had an experience,
I guess I would just ask anyone here,
and I know some of you have come up and told me your experience.
If you've been a planned parenthood patient,
you,
if you've gotten healthcare,
one in five folks in this country have,
tell your story,
posted online,
tell us at planned parenthood,
because those are the voices we have to lift up in this country if we're going
to turn things around and actually go into a future that we,
that we want.
Um,
so thanks a lot.
Thanks.
Yep.
Opinion about the supreme court nominees.
So isn't he the one who physically denied birth control this ugly lot of
companies to deny birth control based on religious beliefs?
Strange.
Um,
should we ask our members of Congress to fight him?
Look at any costs.
Filibuster,
do everything to stop this person.
And then if so then,
but about the Knicks,
we need it.
Yeah.
So it should be a strategy.
Right?
So the question broadly is about the Supreme Court,
um,
and,
and Gorsuch,
who was the nominee?
Um,
first of all,
I just have to,
I can't even answer that without saying it.
Just to me still an outrage that President Obama didn't get a hearing for his
nominee to the supreme court.
It's really,
that was a [inaudible]
that was a betrayal of our,
our,
our constitutional system of government.
And so,
and it has made even more highly partisan and political.
I think the supreme court process,
obviously this nominee is going to be really important.
He has some very disturbing,
uh,
views a about birth control access for women.
Uh,
and I assume more information will come out in hearings.
We feel very strongly at planned parenthood.
We will not support any supreme court nominee who opposes women's rights,
who opposes or suppose as to my friends,
good,
good point.
Reproductive access for all people and abortion rights for people in this
country.
Uh,
Roe versus Wade.
It's important for people to know this,
right?
Which folks have had for more than 40 years hangs by a thread and this nominee
may not make the difference,
but the next one will.
And so it is incredibly important that folks lift up the,
how they feel about these issues and the fact that we are not going to go
backwards in America on abortion rights.
Yeah.
Um,
how do you stay hopeful in times like these weird,
you know,
it just feels like access to healthcare and women's healthcare is kind of under
attack and yeah,
basically how do you stay hopeful
and stay active and not get burnt out?
Yeah.
Um,
it's by meeting a young people like you.
Honestly,
I,
I'm an orbital organizer on my life and I feel like if you're,
or if you work for progressive change,
it's just always going to be tough.
And if it isn't tough,
you're not fighting for the right things.
Uh,
so,
uh,
but I have been encouraged by the amount of public participation now and not
just the marches,
but then what happened at the airports on the immigration bans and the Muslim
bans and the fact that I think progressive,
the progressive community,
uh,
is standing,
together more than ever before.
That's the only way we're actually going to make change.
And in my day to day job,
what gives me sort of the energy in the morning,
uh,
besides getting to come here to Google,
which is a nice vacation from,
uh,
um,
some of this stuff I do is that,
and a friend of mine said this to me,
the day was really important.
Every single day that planned parenthood stays open.
That's basically 8,118 people who got health care that day.
And so I just have to hold them
up here and think about that's why it's worth fighting every single day.
And,
and ultimately,
um,
Tony Kushner wrote in angels in America,
the world only spins forward and I do believe that.
So even in our toughest times,
we just have to keep making sure that the world spins forward.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You have some questions from folks tuning in on the live stream.
Um,
so Tim in San Francisco or San Francisco office is wondering,
um,
in terms of rhetorical strategies,
ways of discussing your response,
um,
in defending abortion,
where do you stand between,
um,
your values based appeals?
You know,
the fundamental right to bodily autonomy for example,
versus pragmatism,
pragmatic based appeals,
you know,
um,
health risks and so forth.
Uh,
I think that the,
the whole topic of abortion in this country for too long was talked about and
sort of this binary political way,
right.
And so in it sort of got labeled many,
many years ago,
decades ago was sort of you're either pro choice or pro life,
whereas most people in this country and particularly young people,
yeah.
Really reject labels and they don't want to be labeled in,
in any way.
And uh,
which I think is a great thing.
I mean,
and so we started a long time ago really to not use those that always,
you know,
there,
I'm sure we lapse sometimes,
but really to talk about to people about abortion as a,
just a deeply personal issue.
Yeah.
Because people do have feelings about it and,
and oftentimes people have had experiences about it.
And I think the question is not,
um,
what would you personally do?
Because I think we really,
it's important to dignify that everyone has to be able to make their own
decisions.
But that basically is the point,
is it everyone needs to be able to make their own decisions.
And that,
and what we have found over and over again is that people in this country,
even in some of the most conservative states,
politically conservative political states believe that at the end of the day,
a person to be able to make their own decision about their pregnancy without the
interference of the,
of the government or their member of Congress.
And,
uh,
you know,
we had an interesting experience in Mississippi and in South Dakota.
Those are states where they tried to ban abortion.
Um,
the legislature passed abortion bans and then it went to the ballot.
And those are states that if you had polled them,
it would have,
they would have come out as being pro life states.
Right.
And folks would have said,
well,
there's no way you're going to defeat an abortion ban.
But in fact,
on election day,
the voters of those two states overwhelmingly rejected these bands.
Yeah.
Because people could,
could have,
there could make the distinction between how they,
they personally felt and what they believe the government,
um,
whether the government should interfere in those kinds of personal decisions.
So I think it's really more and just being willing to have conversations with
folks and we find that when you,
when you acknowledge that people have deeply personal feelings and you're not
trying to push them into a political space,
right?
Just like with everything else in this country,
folks kind of relax and then can have an authentic conversation.
And I just think we need to be doing more of that.
Um,
in America.
How have you seen or have you seen a change in our country?
Um,
how we talk about things,
how we talk to each other.
Have you seen we,
I think it's,
to me it seems like it's gotten worse,
but I don't know if that's just me or where you are on the front lines of this
and some very difficult issues over the last 10 years.
Well,
I mean it's hard to,
I think it's hard to make a blanket statement about that.
I will say something.
And,
and,
and I mean,
it would be dishonest not to say how disturbing it is to see some of the lack of
empathy,
um,
that we're seeing every single day now from some of our political leaders.
Um,
that is,
I just,
we're better than that.
Um,
and,
and again,
I think the lack of empathy for folks whose shoes they've never walked in.
And I guess I,
you know,
I just the,
again,
because I guess it's just so,
so recent,
um,
the stories of transgender people in this country and the barriers they face,
uh,
and the harassment and bullying and the fact that we can't even let them go to a
bathroom that,
uh,
and young people,
it just,
that's heartbreaking to see the,
the lack of compassion for immigrants,
for Muslims,
for people of different,
um,
uh,
countries and backgrounds is extraordinary.
Uh,
and,
and that,
so I,
I feel like we as,
as a community collectively have to do more to reach out to people because I
simply do not believe that is where the majority of this country is.
And we are,
um,
we are not being well represented in Washington DC by folks who are fomenting a
divisiveness,
but it's going to take a lot of us standing together,
um,
to move forward.
But it's tough to see.
It's really tough to see.
Yeah.
Building off what you just said,
we have a Corey also in San Francisco wondering about the balance between
planned parenthood.
It's a national organization and the work you do on the front lines in different
states that have different restrictions and so forth.
So how does,
how do,
how do you work as a national organization at the state level?
Right.
Well,
so as I think I said earlier,
we're really proud that we're in every single state and also we do a lot of work
overseas in Latin America and Africa.
Uh,
and I think that,
you know,
and what our colleagues would would say that it's very different depending on
where you live,
um,
how,
how you operate,
uh,
you know,
providing health care in a rural Wisconsin versus Berkeley versus,
um,
Dallas is different.
But I feel like we are all joined together by a common commitment to make sure
that we serve folks who have the least access,
at least access to care.
But I think it is really important to recognize that it is.
Um,
it's,
um,
there are materially folks in this country who are low income people who have
live in political states where the,
the adversity is huge.
It's really,
really tough.
And,
um,
I,
I guess I can't leave this topic without saying,
you know,
there are a lot of people that inspire me and I've had the good fortune to have
mentors and people who I look up to,
no one inspires me more than the doctors and clinicians that go through sunrise
walk through picket lines and protesters to provide healthcare.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
I,
um,
once,
when I was young,
much younger,
um,
a very dear friend of mine who was in residency and got pregnant from her
boyfriend who had Hodgkin's.
So it wasn't supposed to be able to.
And so she asked me to walk her to the clinic,
to planned parenthood and just to see the screaming and the showing pictures and
this.
And I was like,
I can't imagine.
Right.
And then that's your work environment and that people come because I feel it's
the right thing to do.
It's really amazing.
Uh,
just the commitment and the passion that folks have that provide the care.
And I will say for every angry person with a ugly sign yelling at women,
there are thousands of supporters.
And I think that's what I will say,
even since the election,
just the outpouring of people coming with baked goods to the clinics and to,
you know,
sending Valentine's and,
uh,
that I think too,
someone asked earlier,
what can you do?
It's like,
you know,
hug a clinician today because I can't tell you that that does make a difference
to people.
And,
um,
so,
so that,
that has been amazing.
You know,
last year we had the like,
um,
well it's,
it's,
sorry it's been now I'm more than a year.
Um,
but we had,
you know,
one of the worst shootings in our,
in our history in Colorado Springs and um,
I mean it's,
uh,
it's sort of an unthinkable that that would happen outside of a health center
and the outpouring of support from that community and the fact that our
clinicians are now back at work.
Um,
and providing healthcare in Colorado Springs,
I hope shows the resilience of this community.
I remember the,
the,
the night of the,
after they finally apprehended the gunman and,
uh,
we were on a national phone call,
four with all of our planned parenthood folks around the country about what to
do the next morning because we had folks scheduled for four services and
schedule for a clinical appointments and it was unanimous that we would reopen a
and we would reopen Saturday morning.
And of course,
as always happens when our folks got there to open the doors the next day that
were women lined up outside waiting for us,
just hoping that we would be there for that.
And then so that is,
um,
that is our,
that is our commitment as these doors stay open no matter what.
Yeah.
So I wanna start by probably just thanking you and your organization on behalf
of,
I think sort of all of us here.
I'm sure.
Uh,
it's,
it's sort of awkward to hear you speak so highly of,
of us and the work we do,
we need him.
We,
uh,
you know,
especially given the outpouring of support that planned parenthood got among
Googlers in this past year.
Yes.
I think it's,
uh,
you know,
we are in awe of the work that the organization do.
So yeah,
I guess I'll just take the opportunity to thank you on behalf of all of us who
are,
uh,
admirers of yours.
Okay.
An actual question that you mentioned,
empathy and you know,
me and so many people are struggling with sort of senior,
oh,
that's happening across the country.
Um,
and,
and there's some folks that you,
the three here in the media that probably are lost causes,
we've probably sort of can't really speak to them.
Uh,
I think you and your mom and your family spent a lifetime sort of trying to
convince people who can be turned around,
right,
who are capable of empathy.
I have cases in my own family where people,
you'll logical,
uh,
or religious views that seem to be incompatible with basic empathy.
How,
can you give us some tips for how to reach out to these folks?
Um,
I mean,
it's an important work and I,
I guess I think that we,
if we all start from a point of empathy and trying to really hear and understand
where others are coming from,
that's the best we can do.
And I don't,
I don't think people necessarily change in a moment.
I think they changed from their lived experiences.
Uh,
I mean we see at planned parenthood,
it is,
it is not uncommon to have someone who was picketing our clinic before come in
and bring her daughter in and say,
you know,
I,
we,
we need your care.
We need,
uh,
and,
and I hope that we always carry ourselves in the way that that's what we're
there for is care no matter what.
Uh,
I think,
I do think people telling their stories,
and again,
one of the,
one of the things that I feel like we're not going to change in a way the
politics of this country until we change the culture and cultural attitudes.
And so one of the things that we've been working hard on is to lift up stories
of people because I think it's just harder for people then to me,
statistics and numbers and policies and rights are really not what,
what reach people.
It is literally people's lived experiences.
And,
and that's what I mean,
it's been fascinating to see.
And there were not that many people who don't have some kind of lived
experiences with re some kind of reproductive health issue.
I mean you were talking about your sister and uh,
your experience with your friend.
And I think lifting up those stories and making people think,
because I think the struggle we have sometimes is folks,
they can't relate because they think,
well,
it's never going to be an issue for me.
And for a lot of people in this country,
even when abortion was illegal,
they were able to fly to France or they were able to fly to another country.
And so I think it is really important that we do lift up the stories of the
folks who are affected and who are going to be the most effected if we lose
access to healthcare in America.
Uh,
and that's the best we could do.
Cause I just believe in their core people are good.
Sometimes they're afraid and sometimes they are,
um,
they don't have exposure to other ideas and we just have to keep,
keep trying to lift,
lift those up.
And I,
again,
I've even seen in my short time of planned parenthood that the support,
not only for this organization,
but the engagement and involvement has grown.
And that is to me is just cause you just never quit and never give in.
Uh,
one other thing that to me is just,
this is,
I started getting back to numbers,
but 4 million young people turn 18 every single year in this country.
Okay.
So talk to them.
I mean I just,
I mean I think there are some folks in this country who was sort of like,
are not going to really necessarily be open to new ideas,
but young people are in general,
so eager,
they want to get involved,
they want to do things,
they want to make a difference in the world.
There are more progressive.
They are,
um,
they're,
they're uh,
open to all of us and I think that we have to spend more of our time,
tried to engage them and bring them along and let them break,
make them leaders of this country.
Um,
if the young people of this country lead,
we will change everything.
You sound good.
Thank you.
I wanted to ask,
because this last month has been full of so many news cycles.
And one thing that I think was somewhat is the global gag
rule and how that affected,
uh,
you mentioned your work in other countries,
if he could speak to that.
Right.
So the global gag rule that was signed by the president,
they want,
I believe,
right.
I think before it was really red,
um,
because it was very expansive,
uh,
at not,
it not only threatens access to,
uh,
I mean programs that had been providing family planning,
but programs that provide all kinds of basic maternal healthcare around the
world and,
um,
and women will die as a result.
And that's unacceptable.
Know we made a lot of progress and why I say we,
I mean the collective public health community made a lot of progress in the last
eight years in reducing maternal mortality rates,
uh,
globally and,
and rates of unsafe abortion.
And it's,
it is absolutely unconscionable that we would now go back in a different
direction.
And again,
that's the other reason why it's so important that we,
the politics of this country not only effect is you're saying,
you know,
or as we all know that only affect the people that are in this country,
the effect millions and millions of women nationwide.
And that is so the,
our global policy or is going to be as impactful as some of the decisions that
are being made domestically.
Um,
so it's,
um,
that was very disturbing.
And then I didn't realize someone told me that with the global gag rule also,
you're a woman in serving in the military,
in a country where abortion is illegal,
where you could have gotten it on the base.
Now you're not allowed to.
And I don't,
I don't actually think that relate that the gag rule related to global funds.
But I could be,
I could be wrong though,
but I don't think that actually is connected to that particular executive order.
Um,
and of course the global gag rule,
it's not only about services,
it's about even telling women what their legal rights are in a country.
Um,
you could no longer receive,
receive,
um,
a USA ID money.
So it's um,
farby beyond services.
Yeah.
Um,
you talked a little bit about the change that comes from women actually
governing and obviously we haven't made much strides in that in Congress or in
state legislators.
So I was just wondering if you are hopeful for the next cycles and for 2018 or
if you're seeing more women running for office after what's happening
more women are definitely raising their hand to run for office and I think it's
not just giving congress,
I mean one of the problems is we've got to start like now school boards,
city council.
So if there is anyone in here who wants to run for office,
see me later.
It really is,
I do think folks are just,
I think after this election everyone I know looked up and said,
okay,
what am I doing with my life?
Is there something more I could be doing?
And for a lot of folks that may mean considering running for office and they had
never thought about it before and it,
it makes an enormous difference.
So,
I don't know if you're a potential candidate,
but I would just say don't shake your head.
Uh,
my mom would say,
don't shake your head because I think the problem is a lot of women wait for
someone to come and ask them,
you don't go,
you would be the perfect candidate.
This is going to be,
you know,
great.
And so they wait for everything to be perfect.
So do not wait,
just do it.
Uh,
I,
I think,
um,
mom used to always say that,
that,
um,
and when we talked about this a lot that I think,
and I don't want to be gendered about this,
but I think women have had historically,
um,
they think somehow they're not right for the next thing.
Whether it's running for office for the next job because they don't have the
right degree or they don't know the right people or they didn't take the right
class or they don't speak the right language,
you know,
x this.
And there's always a reason why we're not qualified.
And so just want to say this is a time,
if ever,
in your lifetime to just just do it.
And just take the chance.
Um,
I have seen in Congress,
in the United States Senate every single time and additional woman has come to
United States Senate.
It has made a profound difference in that body.
And,
and as you say,
we've got a long way to go,
but if we could get to more gender equity in,
uh,
in,
um,
in not only in Congress but across the board,
it makes a difference in everything.
So,
um,
I hope you'll run,
I hope that's what you asked.
Okay.
And then for those of you who don't know,
um,
uh,
you worked for Nancy Pelosi.
I did.
I did actually.
Yes.
And she absolutely made,
has made,
I mean,
incredibly impactful in my life has made such a mark in the u s congress.
Yeah.
And,
um,
I think she,
she is so much more deserving of praise and adulation for what she has done in
her years in Congress.
Um,
I feel like she will never get her favor.
Do so just let me just say that to all of you,
you're very,
very lucky to be represented by those who have congresswoman Pelosi as your
representative.
Yeah.
She's amazing.
All right.
Thank you very much for being here today.
This will be emotional for me because I'm a,
it was a big fan of your mothers.
Um,
and having seen also this month,
uh,
the Condoleezza Rice and Secretary Albright speaking in these exceptional women
who stood up and stood out in a time when it was more difficult,
um,
that inspired me to pursue an education and political science.
I started my career the first decade in DC.
A long colorful path has led me here to Google.
Thank you for your advocacy on behalf of planned parenthood.
It is the organization,
but without which the architecture of my life would not have been possible.
And for any one in this room bend,
it doesn't have the experience of a time without access to abortion.
Horrible word,
a horrible thing to not have access to that changes everything about your,
everything about your sister's lives,
your daughters' lives,
the men in your life,
their lives,
the economics of your journey are entirely dependent upon your dominion over
your reproductive healthcare.
They are inextricably connected.
So please advocate,
please march.
Please send money.
Please run for office.
And I will too.
I will see you after and I will raise my hand and I will find a way to,
uh,
represent,
communities with this voice.
[inaudible]
thank you.
Uh,
there is a language problem,
uh,
with,
with the entire concept.
The word abortion has horrible.
Who isn't prolife I have a life.
I like mine.
Sure.
You're enjoying yours.
And who's pro abortion?
How can you say that?
If you've been anywhere near,
if you've walked a friend through those doors,
if you've walked out of those doors yourself,
you cannot be pro abortion.
We have a language problem in the definitions and this has dominion over
yourself,
over your journey,
over your economics.
I think we need to address that.
And then the more subversive me wonders with our current president,
with the history of his women,
of his philandering,
of his pussy grabbing,
couldn't we find possibly someone that he's walked through those doors in and
out?
Every male member,
their daughters,
their lovers have walked in and out of those doors and yet they vote.
And yet they appoint judicial members,
complete contrast and in assault against your right.
Talk through those doors.
How militant should we get?
How subversive could we get?
There's so many questions.
I've got like sell 20 Napkins,
sorry to dump all that.
That's good.
But now,
you know,
how hard are we going to need to fight?
What horrible words are we going to have to use?
What accusations will we have to make?
What outing may we have to perform to get someone to say,
okay,
you got me.
This isn't my decision.
This is yours.
Yep.
No,
I mean,
I don't think we can be subversive enough.
And,
uh,
it's,
I think that's what is exciting to me is seeing,
seeing folks are pushing further than they ever have before,
but we're going to have to,
and,
uh,
so I don't have a,
you know,
I think that you've pretty much outlined what we're against.
I would say that,
that I don't think the question so much is,
and I understand that language matters,
but here's the,
here's the question.
If we,
I think we get to the fundamental question is,
um,
who is in the best position to decide about a pregnancy?
Is it the person who's pregnant or is it an elected official or a politician?
And that's fundamentally where people are at.
You can have your own decisions about what you would do,
but you can never know what another person's situation is.
And that is where we do create empathy,
I think to your question.
Uh,
and we don't try to like push people into political corners and we don't try to
like label them with politics and frankly the evidence,
what I would ask the president of the United States is,
um,
who should make those decisions?
Is it the,
is it the person who has a pregnancy,
uh,
be able to make a decision about that with their doctor,
with their partner,
with their family,
with whoever,
or just for themselves?
Or is it someone who an elective office.
And that is where fundamentally the u s people are on our side.
Um,
and we just simply cannot stand back or be cowed by the rhetoric and fake news
on the other side.
So,
but yeah,
I'll see you later.
Okay.
It's a nasty woman.
I couldn't think of anything more appropriate to wear today.
Thank you.
So I'm also going to start by thanking you for all that you do.
I grew up in Arkansas where I got exposed to avenues abstinence only quote
unquote education,
right?
And now I work for a sex education nonprofit hotline in San Francisco.
And the amount of questions we get from people that do not have the basic
knowledge about their bodies and what is happening to them is staggering.
And we were for many of those people to planned parenthood.
But I'm wondering what we can do to help young people get access to that
information before they even get to the point where they need your services.
Yeah,
I listen for.
So can I just say back at you,
thank you for what you do because it is
so important and there is
the beautiful thing and what are the exciting things about working with Google
and Facebook and Twitter is that there is so much more opportunity,
but there's a lot of bad information out there.
And you know,
we do a text chat program that allowing not just young people but that's
primarily who does it,
just to text with us.
And the same thing,
I mean questions you and unfortunately and is that we've all,
we see this from the moment we started doing the work online.
The most common question is do you think I could be pregnant?
So obviously that conversation needed to happen at a lot sooner and this is
where it is.
You know,
people ask me what's going to happen now with this government?
And one of my biggest fears with HHS as we were going to now completely go
backwards in terms of sex education.
I mean,
it's so backwards.
Texas,
same as Arkansas,
you know,
uh,
our former governor Rick Perry,
who's now a cabinet member,
I can't even believe this,
you know,
was a big abstinence only,
um,
you know,
uh,
proponent because he said it would work for him.
Just like the thought that,
that he never did get pregnant.
There we go.
That's the kind of way
we make.
So we
have got to find more disruptive ways to use technology and to use outreach to
young people.
It's why we've invested so much money,
not only on the tech side but literally like the youth empowerment leadership
wise.
Because I think the,
you know,
the old fashioned part of this too is,
I mean they may find you right?
They may find your service,
but um,
they may just find someone who is a peer in their community.
And to me this has been kind of the underground railroad,
uh,
of planned parenthood for many,
many decades is the young people who are trained to sex educators and advocates
who carry condoms in their,
in their backpack,
who everyone sort of knows.
And we have to sort of combine that I think high touch with high tech outreach
to young people because basically,
you know,
people think that they just come to planned parenthood.
Young people come to us.
I just want birth control.
Basically.
They want someone to talk to,
they want someone to talk to about,
um,
relationships about am I normal?
So common,
just heartbreaking.
You know,
one boob is bigger than the other.
Um,
is there something wrong with me?
This is where young people are at in this country and why it is so heartbreaking
that we have now I think a government that is turning their back on their lived
experience.
So,
uh,
I think we can do more.
That's why I feel like everything we're doing now now is skewing to really 12 to
18 year olds.
Um,
because if we can catch on people early,
we've can empower them,
we can give them information,
we give them access to care and we give them support.
They're going to run this country and they're going to run the world.
Um,
and so,
uh,
I think the dividends are enormous.
Um,
but thank you for doing this work.
And I just,
can I just say,
I,
you know,
I wanted the luckiest people in the world.
I have a job at planned parenthood.
Um,
it's such an honor to work for this organization and,
uh,
it's,
it's just an overwhelming,
um,
I think all of us now at this time in our lives or trying to figure out what do
we do?
You know,
what can we do?
And so I'm grateful to all of you who have raised your hand,
um,
who signed up,
who support us,
who support our patients.
Uh,
this is a time we've never been called to in any way like this before.
And we just gotta be,
we gotta be up to the challenge.
So hang in there.
Our time is out.
And I just wanted to thank you and I also want to point out that,
you know,
I've seen you and watched you,
uh,
and the thing that you've taught me is that no matter how he did the situation
is no matter how much rhetoric or whatever's thrown at you,
you always remain graceful and composed and get your points across.
That may be changing,
but just going to say,
but there's a limit.
There's a limit.
Um,
look,
I,
I think,
well,
I believe on,
on these set of issues.
Yeah.
We have the benefit that,
that people are with us.
And I mean in the broadest possible sense.
And that is where I feel like,
um,
and why I'm just so amazed at the courage of folks just to stand up and speak
out because I really do believe that American people are looking for leadership
right now.
So thank you all for being leaders and here is one.
There we go.
Thank you very much.